c'est pour que la fin des vacances mais
le début de la chasse du mois pour dans
certains endroits sur tout comment les
sangliers deviennent dangereux pour les
cultures dans le village de yuans près
de besançon
hannache hayart a donc ressorti son
vieux fusil à 90 ans elle chasse depuis
70 ans jérôme soûlard et sylvain
gauthier en franche comté
c'est souvent dans ces brumes matinales
grippe est ce que l'on découvre les plus
grands bishr de la chasse des légendes
qui n'ont plus aucun secret pour cette
femme anna chagnard car à 90 ans cette
année rendez vous compte elle est tout
simplement la doyenne des chasseurs
français depuis combien de temps ou
chasser ben itah j'ai cherché hommage
aux que je vais donc elle sonné ok
l'année avec n'est de quoi c'était la
première fois annoncé par est néfaste si
ce n'est pas bien grave
madame shia en tout cas ça fait bien
longtemps en revanche
soixante dix ans après notre chasseresse
n'a toujours pas oublié le
fonctionnement de son fusil man i can't
touch les canidés 16
quant à son dernier gibier ils paradent
ici sur le mur 28 kg pour ce chevreuil
c'était il ya quatre ans quand j'ai et
les champs sur les os
si honda où il n'est pas c'est comme ça
et j'ai lâché mon coup en plein coup du
premier coup oui mais pas deux mais un
bonheur pour anna qui restera un
lointain souvenir car ce matin pour
l'ouverture de la chasse au sanglier
malgré des heures de patience et des
dizaines de rabatteurs on n'a pas vu de
gibier jeu battle a été fait pour les
dégâts d'chez màj a pas de dégâts mais
pas de blessés pas de regret pour un as
carrefour elle la chasse est avant tout
un plaisir de balades et de rencontres
ils viennent tous côtés les chasseurs et
les chasseurs ont go causé dimanche pour
l'ouverture générale à nice et 90
printemps sera bien au rendez vous sa
sacoche à l'épaule et son fusil à la
main le